in
your opinion who concerns you the most i
mean obviously
you know china's at the top where a lot
of people say it's china you got india
that comes up we just kind of figure out
how you're presenting russia to be
what should we be most worried about
again just a year ago
we've never had a shutdown in u.s it's
never been like hey you got a shutdown
four-year california it's barely coming
out of it
take the masks off they came back out
yesterday two days ago put the masks
back on oh no no you can take it off
we've never been through this what are
some other weird things like this that
could happen like what happens to
america and the world if a
real cyber attack actually took place
what does that look like what does life
look like with that can you
use a little bit of creativity to say
you know here's what concerns me and if
this does take place
this is what it will look like let me
paint a picture for you
yeah i mean you asked you know kind of
who among all these state actors to me
is the most concerning
uh and my answer would be us i'm the
most concerned about actually the united
states
and our ability to come together as a
country
and respond coherently in the way we
have done throughout our history
when there is a challenge that presents
itself outside of our borders
and listen and um
you know i remember how in after
september 11th you know
the entire country came together like
this you know very quickly
and before the pandemic and and i'm not
saying this
in any type of person way i'm exhausted
by all the partisanship
but i'm just sitting but i can tell you
you know many times sitting with friends
at dinner over a drink
pre-pandemic kind of wondering you know
as as our society just was keeping
getting more and more divided
like hey you know i wonder if there was
like a 911 type attack you know if there
was a real existential crisis in the
united states like we'd be able to come
together like we did
in the days after september 11th and
talking about that with friends like the
pandemic
presented that type of a crisis i mean
there's 600 000 dead americans right now
based off this pandemic
and 2020 i think was is the most
divisive year we've had since 1968.
that does not bode well for the united
states the um
you know i'm being a little facetious
here but i've always said like you know
like the strength of the united states
like we're kind of like jazz hands you
know like we got all sorts of crazy
stuff going on like people are doing
this they're doing that you know diverse
million that's great and that's a
fantastic way to be
and you can only be diverse like this if
when the moment comes you can take your
jazz hands and you can put them into
fists when you need to
and if you can't put them in the fist
you're gonna get punched right in the
nose
and what concerns me right now is this
co you know the country
with you know just the the the division
that we see the fact that we you know
there's there's so few things we all
agree upon
um that the greatest threat pose the
united states
to me seems to be ourselves and our
inability to get our act together
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]